allez on va jouer on va jouer à barack h
c'est très sain tu vas pouvoir gagner
jusqu'à 2000 euros ring d'accord ma
chérie 2000 euros tu vas devoir choisir
trois défis parmi ces enveloppes pour
100 euros
il faut trouver quelqu'un dans la rue et
faire un slow avec uni pendant 30
secondes en chantant un slot d'accord
quand tu choisis qui aurélie pauvres
pour faire céder si valérie benaïm avec
vous je vais bobl animé par thierry gasc
[Musique]
joal hésitante mais je ne sais plus
serré
monsieur
bravo les filles
c'est le ballon kangoo tu vois 60
secondes pour trouver quelqu'un ait
sauté avec lui sur un ballon kangoo à
dire tu vas sortir et voilà pour que
vous soyez tous les deux dans la rue
comme des contraintes sauter sur un
ballon qu'hambourg tu vois qui pour
remplir ce défi j'arrivais le maire si
je le sens pas belle la vie
l'argent n'est pas apparue la daurade
aléa moral
[Applaudissements]
bon voilà je tiens à y ait des chiens
c'est bon merci beaucoup merci à ces pas
attention quand tu traverses d'april à 7
hélas oui c'est plus compliqué on va
jouer pour 200 euros
il va falloir trouver et ramener une
personne qui porte un sous vêtement bleu
n'ont pas l'enlever one ou montré
d'accord dans la rue tu choisis et qui
pour y aller excusez moi monsieur
ah oui quand-même jamais retrouvé plein
quelle couleur est venu de lui vous
n'avez ainsi mme blot par hasard bon un
slip bleu merde et vous le dira si les
bleus font alors bon alors tu sais quoi
même si quelqu'un tout le monde c'est
sous maintenant régaler à l'otan par
elle convient de laisser là on peut
normalement c'est perdu on va les années
s'est un peu cherché à nous attention il
ya un camion quand même mais si
attention à toi mais je vous avais un
sous vêtement bleu voyez bien je leur
date de la première étape à ce vêtement
bleu mais si tu trouves pas ils ont pesé
sur la demande mais pas un bleu baba
devant nous qu'on clé là le pompiers ou
badauds mantois sous-vêtement moulin
nous avait contrôlé à l'acte et pas mal
comme isabelle en mai oui mais bon pas
rester malheureusement tu à 150 euros de
côté mais pour valider ce défi pour
valider cette somme il va falloir que
tommy arrive à relever le défi mystère
tu tony à 60 secondes pour trouver
quelqu'un dans la rue qui va devoir le
porter
jusqu'ici je me rende mon teint hâlé or
tu dois trouver quelqu'un d'autre
au pire des cas si ta personne au bout
de cinquante secondes tu peux prendre
motta stone il tue parce qu'on a 110 110
5 paquets force malgré montella par
ailleurs possible tout est dans le
mental a essayé d'accéder au son des
cuivres le dos
c'est un passant qui ça peut le faire à
temps la tête avec robin williams va
plaire à personne
on va pour elle s'est imposée aux
maladies et c'est benji d'abord benji sa
vache à lait belges y aller mais jim
hâlés 28
[Applaudissements]
ce mardi
huawei à bombay
[Applaudissements]
non
ma chérie j'ai relevé tu multiplies tega
par deux et hugues and 300 ma chérie
[Applaudissements]